Okay, thank you.
Just a moment.
I'm sharing my screen, Team. Let me know once it's there on your screens, really quick.
Must be there.
Support.
Hey, gotcha.
Yep, go ahead.
Alright, thank you. Excuse me for my bad throat.
So...
How do you like this presentation? I mean, graphical presentation. So this is our global team, India, Philippines, US teams. I mean, last year they collaborated, they all got together during Build It Event in the US.
So, you know, this is where we have put it here and two logos, you know, partnership, depicting partnership, ITBD and SpiderNet. So, we got your logo, you know, from Google. We researched on it and yeah, so this is a weekly service review which we'll be presenting going forward. So,
Currently, this is just a sample which I'm presenting to you that represents from May 18th to 22, so that you'll have an idea how it's going to be.
Moving on to, yeah, agenda. So this week, the agenda is executive summary, performance review, governance, ITBD service offerings, team GPS. This is our homegrown tool. We'll discuss more on it in the following slides.
Got it.
AI by design, this is this is ITBD initiative on AI stuff. Holiday schedule and way forward with Spider Net Consulting.
Technical Consulting. Executive summary. So highlights onboarding and warm handover completed successfully. Sam has started working with Team Spider Net Technical Consulting LLC and he's presently shadowing with the team and he's getting familiar with the tool sets and daily.
Triage at your end.
Glow lights, I'm mentioning Suzanne's personal health. That's the only thing would be observed as of now. However, we would love to hear from you if you or your team has observed anything that we should be paying attention on.
No, I mean, he's...
He's a forward thinker. He wants to get in there. I think he's a little nervous, but that makes sense. I mean, we're...
pushing them to get in there, but you know, it's early, right? It's pretty early. We don't usually push people that fast to get into things, but you know, he seems, he seems like he's willing and able to jump in if needed and...
Yeah.
So it's.
It's good.
Thank you, Anthony. That's really a good gesture. And I appreciate you understanding that. Yeah, absolutely. He's new in the team. And yes, gradually, he'll be picking up things. He'll pick up his pace and we'll move along, you know, as, you know, things come to his plate.
So as of now, help required, initiate support from the team from both sides. So ITBD and SpiderNet, we both are working along with him if he needs any support. So yeah, that's it. That's general.
Moving on to next slide. Performance review. So going forward, this slide will be.
representing graphs.
and his performance in the form of text. So we'll mention some insights, you know, what are his challenges, if he's doing good, whether he's meeting targets or he's exceeding expectations, and what are his actual numbers. So we have some KPIs, KRAs as per the scorecard.
So we'll showcase that piece of information here. So this was his target and this is exactly what he achieved. And going forward, the process is for initial days, at least for 90 days. So we'll slowly and gradually, so we'll, as of now, we'll be having weekly service calls.
Then we'll move to, I mean, I'm not measuring here, but we'll be, you know, as you and I feel comfortable, we'll move to bi-weekly service calls slowly and gradually as things will settle down. And then from bi-weekly to monthly, then quarterly. So quarterly calls.
meetings are not necessarily for engineer review. This is from business standpoint. How ITBD as whole is working, you know, with you and what are...
the areas from business standpoint where we can help each other, understand each other, support each other, and yeah, discuss each other's challenges and yeah, future growth plans and all that.
Discus highlights, lowlights, yeah.
So.
Yeah, sorry, sorry to interrupt you again. Yeah, so anything talking about the KPIs. So here we are talking about some certain KPIs that my team is following, be it number of ticket they are closing, or you want to talk about the utilization. So in case if you have any existing KPIs that you're following for your engineers and you want Sam to be, you know, in those KPIs.
Sorry, I didn't say that. Sorry.
then you can just let us know as well.
Sounds good.
So, we can we can customize our KPIs and then a quarterly, as Gagan was saying, that is a quarterly business review. So, primarily, you know, we we have our executive team, we our directors, our CX director or CEO or CTO people, like you know, someone from that team, they can join the quarterly business review.
with the same set of people from your side as well, so that, you know, we can have a discussion around business. Do you need more SAM? Or how can we, you know, expand our business? How can we expand this partnership going onwards? So that is the goal of a quarterly connect.
Actually, Gagan, yeah.
Got it.
Good.
Thank you, Michelle, for covering this, and...
Yeah, the third point was purpose, continual improvements, and risk and provide mitigation. So this is what we'll be discussing going forward.
Performance analysis sample. Yeah, this is going to be the sample. So this is how we present. On the right hand side, we have insights. What are our target for this? For instance, you know, this slide is representing utilization trend analysis.
which is billable versus non-available time, what is his time, whether there are any challenges, or is able to meet his productivity on a daily basis, daily, weekly basis. So for instance, ITBD billable target is 80%.
However, depending upon the ticket inflow, if you think your environment has, you know, more number of service requests or, I mean, different clients have different environments. For instance, you have more number of incidents, more number of alerts, or more number of service requests, so depending upon that.
If he touches those number of tickets and how much billable time he can contribute in a day or in a week, so I can we can gauge that performance in the first week or second weeks and going forward, you can review those things if he's.
If things are going fine, going smooth, and meeting your expectations, so we can go the same way otherwise. At any point of time, as Vishal said, if we need to alter the targets, so we can do that. Okay, meeting your expectations.
The target, right, the target we have is 85%.
Okay, is that billable, non-billable, both, or just billable? Both? Okay, 85. Yeah, thank you. So that makes sense.
Both.
Mhm.
And that, that excludes.
Rick.
Or, and it, but yeah, yeah, well, I actually it does include break, so, so...
So 85% is the utilization that should be the admin one or the billable one I would say and the 15% is.
Including lunches, right?
Bill and non-billable.
Yep, okay, understood. Yeah.
Right.
So that essentially factors in lunchtime in there to bring the number to 85.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Yeah, that makes sense. Thank you.
And yeah, thank you for chiming in. We would love to hear more from you. If you think there's anything, you know, also during this presentation or, you know, after reviewing this entire presentation, there's anything that probably we are not covering, but you want those specific things to be covered.
In this presentation, we would love to do that as well.
So in generally, when I say 85%, what we're shooting for is 33 and a half hours a week.
He might exceed it based because he has like a, I think his hours are a little longer than normal, so than what we're used to. So, and depending on how, you know, how we have some people at the company that are 90, 100, you know, so.
Mhm, mhm.
Mhm.
It's, that's the base, that's sort of like the bumper, the guardrail, but we'd like to see 85 or higher.
Yeah.
Minimum benchmark, I get you. So I can say that's minimum benchmark, 85%. Of course, we always encourage engineers to meet and exceed their targets, what is set for them. Otherwise, because once the target is set, if they go below their target, so.
They get a markdown on their scorecard, so I mean they anyhow tend to meet their targets. Thank you, Anthony, for your inputs. So, ticket closure trends, so this is how we present in number of tickets he worked.
Good.
number of tickets he closed. So based on that calculation, it shows, you know, whether he's at, you know, 50%. This is just an example. I mean, we always want him to, because you can see that the amber line is on 80%. So we want them to test this line or exceed this line all the time.
Ohh.
I also need to know, most of the times, okay, we calculate, I'll just explain how we calculate.
If he needs to work mostly on incident tickets and service request tickets, there are more chances at least 80% tickets will be closed same day. But if he is also included in some project work, you know, project, we know that project work, you know, tickets go for a few days.
Of that, get it computed same day, it it may run for you know two or three days, so those only so project is one of the examples which will affect the ticket resolve rate, but if there's if the project so that way either we can alter the target or...
The projects are not in picture.
The regular stuff, incidents, alerts, or service requests, they will be, they will let him meet his target of minimum 80%.
Got it.
Any thoughts from you?
I feel like we need to get rolling to sort of like figure out how we how we sort of recalibrate, right? So, you know, I I let's see how we progress and we'll see we'll see what that what that needs to be.
Mhm, Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you. And I need to know, just like you mentioned, your time target is 85. So what is the target for ticket closure at your end?
Well, we don't generally track that, right? So we're not tracking the close rate. Maybe we should. But generally speaking, most of these L1, L2 tasks, they're closable. And we'll rely on our CSAT score.
Okay.
Uh, to to define how that.
Mhm.
how that looks, right? So.
We're expecting a high CSAT score.
Yeah.
which will translate into closure tickets and success on the tickets, right?
Yeah, definitely.
Like we're sharing that.
So when we are talking about CSAT, do we have any target for them? Like, you know, 95% is your CSAT score? That should be the score or for some of our client, they target 95 sometime. Some of us, they do target like 98%. Any target you have for your engineers?
Yes.
Yeah, I mean, right now where it's at, it's pretty high. We post it to the website, but let me just see where it's.
Okay.
I, I get I get very nervous when so right now it's really high, but I get nervous if I see if I see that start to get closer to 92.
91%, I start to get nervous, right? But that's, but remember, that's a collective average. So it's not necessarily stand by himself. So, but you know, if I see a bad review, I'll request that the technician go back, get whatever is, you know, get the, get the, get it reversed.
I.
Mhm.
I understand.
Okay.
So they'll go back, they'll say, listen, I, you know, you've rated this bad. I need, you know, look, what can I do to make you rate this great? How do I fix, how do I fix this? Right? And so they'll go back, fix it. That's that. It's rare that that happens, but.
It still happens, right? So, as far as, as far as a number, if I were to guess, I would say...
It was, that's like I said, that's the average, not the not the individual person, so...
I like seeing great goods. You know, we use crews, so, you know, you know how goods are, right? Goods are basically bad. So, so as long as you can get the goods, I'm good, you know.
Yup.
OK, OK, so Sam will be able to see that those scores, like, you know, how many, how many CSAT he's receiving.
Yeah, so...
He will have access to those. Okay.
He won't see bads, but we don't advertise the bads to the employees sometimes unless we have to, right? But the goods and the greats, yeah, sometimes you don't want to create that environment where...
Oh, okay.
If there's negative feelings, right? So, um, but let's let's...
No, I understand that. Yeah.
Let's evaluate that situation as we flow through.
No, that sounds like a plan. Thank you. In case if you have any feedback for Sam, then this is your group. You can always come back to us, either me or Gagan, and just let us know in case if you have any feedback for Sam. It's not like that you have to wait for these call, these service call to happen. We will be available over team chat. So just drop a message and one of us will respond.
Perfect.
Thank you so much. Yeah, back to you, Gagan.
Yeah, thank you, Michelle. Thank you, Anthony. Moving on to ITBD analysis. So, well, this is a monthly basis. So, of course, in the first month will not be, we may not trigger this. I mean, Vishal, you may know more about this.
So probably we'll trigger C-site survey from the second month onward. Okay, so yeah.
So, so every month, every month, you know exactly what Gagan is saying. Every month, we do trigger a CSAT survey that will come to you, Anthony, I believe, right? And I have not seen the complete list, but some of the stakeholders from from SpiderNet, they will get the CSAT survey. So, this is for Sam, how he is doing.
So, you all we have you have 3 emojis over there: smiley, neutral, or...
bad survey you can see or negative survey. So you just need to click one of those emojis and then that will come back to us. So talking about your experience with SAM, that is CSAT. So you will get two kind of surveys from us. One is going to the CSAT if you are happy with SAM. Second is NPS, Net Remoter Score. That is what we are triggering once in a quarter.
If you are happy with ITBD services, then you just need to rate our services. And if you are going to promote our services to your colleagues, your friends, so that is where you need to rate us between 1 to 10. So 9, 10 means we are doing great, and you're more than happy with ITBD. You're going to promote our services. Eight is neutral, where you believe that, okay, there's a scope of improvement for ITBD.
Still, we can, we can, we can have some have some improvement over there, and anything less than eight means you're not happy, and that is that is negative on our services. So, so these are the two services you will expect from us.
Got it.
OK.
Thank you, thank you, Vishal, and...
Moving on to ITBD service offerings, Rick has dropped already. I think he must have discussed with you about Build It Live event, which ITBD holds every year. And this year, this is, again, I mean, every year this is for three days. So this year,
This is from August 3rd to 5th, 9 A.m. to 5 P.m.
in Hyatt, which is on Hudson River, Jersey City, New Jersey. And so, I mean, more details can be shared with you.
Rick, Rick must have spoken. Rick must have spoken to you regarding this, Anthony, and I'm pretty certain you or SpiderNet team will be there on the event.
Yeah, we're we're still mulling it over, but yeah, it's but I know we signed up just prior to the to the to the pandemic, and then you know that whole thing happened, so, but yeah, no, it's I get it, you guys are pretty close and you know we're in Philly, so yeah, it's a few hours.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're in Pennsylvania, right? So just neighboring state. Yeah.
Yeah, yep.
Appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
And I'm sure you know already about this as well. This is ITBD's homegrown tool. This is Team GPS with AI features. So these are some of the features we have highlighted here. So if you're looking for some tool that can, you know, have
collaborative one-on-one group meetings, employee engagement activities, client management, performance management tracking, the boards and recognition, strategic goals alignment, and many more. Everything is not mentioned here, so which is why I'm in, if you're interested, so
A little screenshot of the tool is on the upper right corner. You can see. You can scan this QR code and our team will be there to set up time to give you the demo of this tool. If you like it, I mean, you can proceed with it and let us know. I mean,
how you liked it. And if you think it still needs to be improved, you know, you need some extra features. So because there's a homegrown tool, so our team is capable of capable enough to meet required changes and augmentation accordingly.
Gotcha.
Yeah, this is also, I'm sure our Pre Sales team or marketing team, customer experience team must have discussed with you. So, these are some of the ITBD AI initiatives we are working on. So, we so we have Rus Consulting, Synthrio.
GPT coding portals, agent as service, AI leadership accelerator, build it, peer groups, Team GPS with AI.
So, apart from Build It, we do also organize various AI enablement events, so wherein we...
We coach MSPs on AI, you know, how they can introduce AI in their environment and do better and make their team more efficient.
That's it. And this is ITBD's holiday calendar for 2026. So on the left hand side, you see these are compulsory holidays. These can be marked on your calendar. I think we did discuss this previously as well. So these can be marked on your calendar. On the right hand side, you see these are optional holidays. So apart from these,
Eight compulsory holidays, we give them, you know, five options to choose, choose two, so...
I need to still check with Sam. You know, March is already gone, so future months will be October or November. So we have ample time to decide on these option holidays. But at least we'll let you know three to four weeks in advance that what day he has selected or opted for his.
Uh, you know, option holiday.
However, if you think there is some business requirement, you know, for Sam to work that day, you can let us know and we can speak to him so that he can accommodate and work that day and, you know, take, you know, complimentary of later on.
Got it.
Way forward, our emphasis would be to send to remain focused on his KPI and ITBD to support Sam in maintaining his productivity and identifying any areas where, you know, you know, you know, we can add more value. And of course, we, from my side,
And from my leadership side, we do organize, we have healthy environment here. So we do organize, you know, weekly get together with a team. We have a good, spacious cafeteria in the office. So sometimes, you know, we on a Friday, we order pizza hour.
you know, something outside. So we sit together, a team who work with other clients at the same time. So, which, you know, we spend some good time on a monthly basis or quarterly basis. We go outside, we dine together, either lunch or dinner.
I will send you, I'll share pictures with you as well. I mean, how we do celebrate and on annual basis. Sunny, our CEO, he visits India along with some other US team members as well. And we celebrate our annual.
day here in India. And most of the times, like I said, so US team is not, I guess, comfortable with India summer, so which is why it is celebrated in winters in India. Mostly in November, October and November, or sometimes in February or March.
So those are the months when we celebrate our annual day. And sometimes we do, along with that, organize, partner retreat at the same time when we collaborate and...
Yeah, with our partners so that they visit India, give them a good opportunity, you know, so that they visit New Delhi. Have you ever been to, or you must have seen in picture, if you have never been to India, I'm sorry, Taj Mahal?
I have not. I have not.
You're not visitor, but you must have heard of Taj Mahal, right? Or Golden Temple.
Oh, the Taj Mahal? Oh, yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yes, that's cool.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. So these are some of the historic great places, you know, which I have people worldwide. I mean, every country has some monuments, some places which they have in their bucket list that one day they will, you know, go in and see those things. So, so this is this is in our
Right.
Itinerary whenever Partner visit India, so they go to these places, Golden Temple as well, and and in India we have three sites now: New Delhi, Noida, as well as Chandigarh. Chandigarh is the original site from it from.
where ITBD grew and started. And, you know, and now our headquarters in New Jersey. So you will get to see a lot of places and will be very happy and meet you in person. Your team, Sam, will be able to meet you in person if this happens. And I'm sure you'll be able to make it.
Nice.
That's cool.
Yeah, absolutely.
Awesome.
That is committee all from my end. So let me unshare my screen. So Anthony, anything that you probably notice we did not cover in this slide, but it should have been here. So we can make alter, make changes in our presentation accordingly.
Yeah, no, it's good. I just, you know, just, you know, like you and I talked about, once we get to get some traction.
Yeah.
and start to make some headway. I think it'll be...
We'll gain more clarity on on on on those on the details of of what you shared, right?
Um...
Yeah, he seems to be a very systematic thinker, which is good. You know, he doesn't have that, which is a good thing. He doesn't have that like American mind where
Mm-hmm.
Just, you know, he thinks he knows everything and he doesn't know anything. Like, that's just the way we are over here, right? We just think we know everything, and he's, he's respectful and he wants, he wants to do good, and it's a nice, it's a nice change of culture.
Mmh.
To to see.
Somebody, you know.
Um, just...
Be authentic and want to do the best you can, right?
So it's.
Yeah.
Yep, I totally second you on that actually. He's a very smart worker at the same time. He's very polite. That is where, you know, he brings that value to us. Apology to see this hiccup so early with his health, but this was something non-controllable. So.
Yeah, I mean, I'm not really expecting him tomorrow to be in, you know, just because he will need some time to recover, but hopefully things will go better and he will be there on Friday. I totally appreciate your support on this, Anthony. So we will keep you posted on that.
Yeah.
Gotcha. That sounds good.
And on a lighter note, I think you're a fitness enthusiast, right? Are you?
I, I, I have been lately, yeah, that's true, yeah.
So yeah, so you will have good collaboration with Sam because you know he is on same lines. I mean, as he takes good care of his, you know, physical health, I mean, muscles and everything. Yeah, so you can have a discussion on this topic as well. You have one extra topic.
Good, good deal. That's good to know. Yeah, awesome.
Apart from work, yeah.
Anything else from you, Michelle? Yeah.
Thanks for joining.
Yeah, thank you, Anthony, for your time. Have a great day. Yeah, bye-bye.
Thank you so much.
All right, take care.